[Applaudissements]
une action est à vouloir nommer ne
donnait rien si m la somme est de dos
avec une perruque on lance la musique
des feux de l'amour c'est de retourner
les feux de l'amour l'autre pose sa main
sur l'épaule de son binôme ai dit je te
pardonne richard le vert vous embrasser
c'est le retourner les feux de l'amour
alors vous mettez chacun une perruque
6,6 ici attention à l'état ne veut pas
je peux pas aller si vous allez vous
mettre là devant vous mettre devant dos
à dos et vous êtes dans les feux de
l'amour
on se place oui vous vous êtes
embrouillé il faut vraiment galoche à la
fin oui vagues allant jusqu'à l'os il
vient d'nrj12 on sait mettez vous debout
au revoir à tout cas
pas besoin de parler là j'espère la
réplique à matthew sera sauf offre à du
cinéma un gic sont vraiment coiffé comme
ça et je feux de l'amour y est quoi mais
après je te pardonne richa phrase il ne
t'est même les chevaliers du fiel ont
entendu les progressistes et pardonne
richard s'est on a mûri
c'est horrible j'ai l'impression de vous
tromper
[Musique]
c'était pardonne fesci
j'ai mal joué mais je te pardonne au
sila à moi maintenant
[Applaudissements]
non
parfait mais dans l'autre sens d'une
fête richard
il sait pas embrassés et qui ne s'est
pas embrasser ne sait pas aimer
il me dit non non non c'est pas
attention et les ont tués coureurs et v2
inspiré que toi va alors à quoi tout cas
radio lâchant des vous en tout cas c'est
mylène farmer futur inouïe alors mais
qu'est-ce que ça le fait audi riches à
une pop star est allé au rival
l'attention mêlant retournez-vous de
l'autre côté on les caméras
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai beaucoup milité dans mon ranch du
wyoming et sache je te pardonne un chat
[Musique]
non
bravo monsieur merci match au point
jeudi soir les gones face non c'est non
merci
non merci dans les caves y rester là à
rester là camille parce que en fait je
pense qu'on a on est on n'aura pas mieux
1 ce soir dans les mots non la vérité
mais on a vu des boules on a fait de la
vérité donc on pourra pas aller plus
loin je pense moi faire les pollutions
mayence you il aime l'ail est en tout
cas alors que vous allez dire ce n'était
pas désagréable